So, how did you blow up your YouTube
channel?
No, like genuinely how did you get so
many
>> 196,000 subscribers?
Seriously, what's your secret, dude?
What's my secret?
Well, I wish I could say it's all about
the fancy beard, but it's not.
I spent the last 2 years trying to
answer this [music] question. I've shown
you my editing process, how I write my
scripts, how I design thumbnails, but
apparently
that's [music] not all.
There are so many tiny details that even
I didn't realize I was doing in my own
videos. The things [music] that make you
watch till the very end almost
subconsciously.
But I finally put it all together, I
think. Every rule, every decision, every
secret and combined them into the video
you're watching right now.
Pick a niche,
they say, [music] and start making
videos about the topics inside that
niche. Fitness, cooking, movies,
science, YouTube growth. Just choose it
right and everything else follows,
right?
Well,
kind of.
Okay, that's actually a terrible advice.
I mean, a niche is just a topic and
topics alone don't actually make people
subscribe to your channel. When I
started this channel, I didn't say,
"Okay, I'm going to make videos about
YouTube growth. There are 3,258
channels out there already doing that.
Hey everyone, so I'd be the new guy in
the same room making the same videos,
just worse. How would you even stand out
here?" You don't. [music] You're done.
Finito. Instead, I told myself, "I'm
going to take people who make robotic,
soulless videos and teach them how to
make videos like an actual human." And I
mean, I think it's going pretty well for
now. So, the difference isn't the topic,
it's the transformation. What does an
ideal viewer walk away knowing or
feeling after watching your video? Not
YouTube advice channel, but I finally
understand why my videos suck. And this
guy explains it without making me feel
stupid most of the time. Channel.
[music] See the difference?
But it doesn't really matter if your
video idea sucks.
Now, the best way to find solid video
ideas is using your brain, but I don't
like doing that. So, let me show you the
second best way, finding outlier videos,
ideally in a completely different topic.
It's a video that performs 10 or even
100 times better than a regular video on
that channel. If a dude usually gets
1,000 views and suddenly drops a banger
with 100,000,
>> [music]
>> that's an outlier. It doesn't happen on
accident. Something about it worked and
your job is to figure out what. There
are many [music] tools out there to find
outlier videos, but honestly, just open
YouTube and start scrolling. Trust me,
if a video is an outlier, you don't need
to find it, it will find you. And once
you find one, watch it till [music] the
end. Analyze it. Why it worked so well.
Is it the thumbnail? Is it the intro,
the story, the fact that a guy went from
pre-diabetes to running an Ironman in
100 [music] days while managing to
connect a whole thing to a philosophical
self-reflection that makes everybody
relate to it in their own lives? Write
that down [music] and use it in your
next video. Whoa.
Dude, couldn't you knock? I'm in the
middle of a video here.
>> [laughter]
>> That's how you meet your best friend
after a month? Yeah, where have you
been, man?
Working on something. What kind of
something?
I launched my own store. A store?
Cool, right?
Look [music] at that subtle off-white
coloring, tasteful thickness of it. Oh
my god, it even has a dot store domain.
Something wrong?
Dot store? Not dot com? Oh, my store's
domain name? Yeah, it's way more
memorable and cleaner than whatever
those platforms give you by default.
>> watch the last video, did you? Uh, I
read the AI summary of it.
Oh.
A dot store domain is built for creators
who sell stuff online. Instead of those
ugly default links, it's just your name
dot [music] store. It's easy to share,
easy to remember, and easy to put in
your fancy business card.
>> get way [music] more clicks as well
because people know it's a store
straight away.
>> And more clicks means more sales.
>> You probably saw this before. Mr. Beast,
[music] IShowSpeed, Press Publish, Dude
Perfect, Zach King, and
>> Yeah, basically any creator who takes
their brand seriously already has one.
Size doesn't matter. [music]
>> Dude, wait. What? So, we both have a dot
store domain. Yeah. Then who are we
telling all that for?
For him.
So, if you're a creator [music] selling
anything online or just thinking of
starting, grab your dot store domain at
the link in the description and use the
code Isaac Verse at checkout for a nice
discount. Huge thanks to my friends at
dot store domains for sponsoring the
channel.
Now, back [clears throat] to the video.
So, you know the story. Greeks couldn't
get into Troy for 10 years, so they
built a giant wooden horse, hid [music]
soldiers inside, and left it as a gift.
Trojans took the horse, Greeks jumped
out, destroyed everything. What the hell
does this have to do with YouTube? Well,
if you think about it, we're doing the
same thing. Look, it's unfortunate, but
nobody wants pure [music] knowledge, so
you have to put it inside a Trojan
horse. I'm not just talking about a
fancy title and thumbnail, you know that
already. It's about every single layer,
editing, animation, script. They're all
parts of the [music] horse. The
information inside is identical, but how
you present it makes all the difference.
I've already made separate videos about
these, [music] so I'm not going to get
into details here. You can check them
out after this one if you want.
In YouTube Studio, click advanced mode,
metrics, and [music] average views per
viewer. This number tells you how many
videos the average person watched
[music] on your channel. 1.7 is good for
posting once every 6 months, I guess.
Basically, if it's higher than one, that
means people watched more than one video
in the last 90 days. And there's one
thing that improves this number than
anything else. Look at these videos.
What do you see? They explain different
topics, but they follow a single format.
[music] How I actually edit viral
videos, how I actually write viral
scripts, make viral shorts, thumbnail,
voice over. If someone clicks on the
editing tutorial and likes it, what does
he do next? He watches [music] the
thumbnail tutorial as well, and then
scripting, and then shorts, and then
voice over because it feels like a show
with new episodes. Makes the algorithm
push the channel's videos to a bigger
audience each time you post a new video
in that format. All the old ones grow
with it. New viewers find the latest
video, then binge the whole back
catalog. Average views per viewer
increase and that cycle makes your
channel grow exponentially. [music] So,
if you want to grow your channel, having
a back catalog of videos with a similar
format is much more valuable than having
one viral video. And I didn't invent
this concept, by the way. All the big
YouTubers have their own formats. Mr.
Beast has $1 versus $1 something.
Finzar, Enrico Daredevil Bog. You get
the point. So, don't focus on coming up
with a viral idea for each video. Try to
find with a viral format your audience
likes and you got yourself a loyal
audience.
Let me tell you something no one tells
you before you start. Nobody is going to
come up to you one day and say, "Okay,
you're officially an expert [music] now.
You may begin." So, if you're waiting
for that moment before starting to share
anything, you're missing the point of
the internet, dude. But the good news is
you don't need it anyways because
YouTube is full of experts. What's
actually missing is more honest guides.
I mean, see yourself as just a random
guy who's learning out loud and
documenting his [music] findings. I
don't make these videos as some flawless
guru sitting on the, I don't know, 58th
step of the journey. I'm [music]
probably just a few steps ahead sharing
what I learned with people who are a few
steps behind. That's it. And to be
honest, every time I post, I also think,
"Oh, this is too basic. Everyone already
knows this." But when I share the video,
there are hundreds of people saying it's
their first time hearing this. I hope
you guys don't say it just to make me
feel better. So, what feels obvious to
you can be the missing piece for someone
else. People don't want a guru's advice
who probably already forgot what being a
beginner felt like 10 years [music] ago.
Half the time the methods those guys
used to get there are completely
irrelevant today anyways. Think about
[music] it this way. When your professor
explains a new concept, you don't get
it. But when your friend explains the
exact [music] same thing, suddenly
everything makes sense because your
friend still remembers what knowing it
felt like. Same logic. That's why a
simple video like I tried YouTube shorts
for a year always beats how to make 100K
per day with YouTube automation.
When you're analyzing all these massive
[music]
channels and comparing your videos with
theirs, at some point you probably felt
like [music] you're just too behind. But
here's what you're forgetting. They've
been doing this for 8 years. [music]
You're comparing your third video to
their 300th. And look, even my channel,
I see so many people just look at it and
say, "Wow, he blew up with just eight
videos." Yeah, no. Sure, my first video
was terrible compared to my last one,
but here's the thing. This isn't my
first video. I made over 100 videos in
my previous movie channel just to learn
editing, storytelling, [music]
and failing. Nobody watched them, but
that was the point. So, when you see a
channel ahead of you, try to look at the
big picture. Don't compare your chapter
one with someone's chapter 100.
So, what do you do?
I mean, you can try to fix the
thumbnail, the hook, pacing, music,
color grading, story, voice over all at
once, or just pick one thing that felt
the weakest last time and ignore
everything else until you make it good.
Because if you try to fix everything at
once, you just get overwhelmed by how
many things you should fix and you stop
enjoying making videos. Just [music]
give yourself permission to suck for the
first 10, even 100 videos. Okay, this
may sound wrong, but if you've never
made a video before, you can straight up
copy someone else's video. Not steal,
just recreate for educational purposes.
Take a video you liked and try to remake
it yourself. It will teach you what it
takes to make a video like this.
So, you've got the knowledge, the
format, the mindset, everything we
talked about. You know more about
growing a YouTube channel than 90% of
people who want to. And
you're still not going going it, are
you?
Photoshop.
Photoshop, baby.
So, who's this guy?
>> Without further ado, let's get
>> This dude [music] blew up in 6 months.
I'm trying to figure out how.
What happened to the last one? It was a
different approach, more storytelling,
[music]
but used less editing than this guy. How
long have you been doing this?
A few hours. [music] Today?
Uh yeah.
You look happy.
I mean, yeah. Learning this stuff is
fascinating. [music]
I get so much knowledge to use in my own
channel.
What? Dude, what the hell are you doing?
>> That's your problem. You feel like
you're working, but you're not.
>> I'm learning from others.
>> in everyone else's channel.
When are you going to start yours?
What's that?
Your launch date in 30 days. But I can't
>> have a video until then.
>> [music]